what I proposed I've actually written
two sections of as I got into it as
often happens at home with no one more
turn right and less and less time to
actually do it so I'm going to read some
of it and then towards the end I'll just
sort of go through these these talking
points and then we can get into some
good discussion hopefully buddy on some
and I've been wanting to an an an some
in a marriage and sexual desire for for
a long time there's not a lawful lot in
Anselm about these topics so you have to
to some degree extrapolate from his
writings on other things for example as
many discussions of the friendship we'll
see why in just a moment that's not
actually in here what I would have in
here is the stuff where he actually does
talk at least you know tangentially this
is about marriage Kandra along sexual
desire he doesn't use the term conjugal
love which is going to come about it's
going to there's any sort of flowering
of monastic writing on marriage love all
these sorts of things in the 12th
century but ansem is not really in that
current until he's a little bit before
then so what can we call out of texts by
or about and so having to do with these
topics one particularly fruitful
discussion to examine occurs in the Vita
on cell me traveling in England at
monastery business he Anselm assualt up
a people of all orders of life that is
monks clerics and laypeople and he
orders his conversations with them to
their ways of life and their their
characters including to the married lady
you have that extended passage there to
married persons who taught how great was
the fidelity love and companionship with
which they should be bound together both
in matters pertaining to God and the
things of this world the man on his side
should love his wife as himself knowing
none other but her having regard for the
welfare of her body as of his own and
entertaining no evil suspicions but the
woman like why should submit to her
husband with all loving obedience that
she should diligently encourage him and
while doing and calm his spirit with her
mildness if you were chance unjustly
it up against anyone so this is a
passage very rich in implications one of
these is that Anselm clearly regards
marriage as a relationship whose
purposes or ends cannot be reduced to
social order mutual usefulness enjoyment
of sexual pleasure or even procreation
those bound together the commutative
ought to engage in intercourse oriented
and inhabited especially by this mutual
fidelity love and companionship marriage
is its own sort of friendship calling
for the random re loving in return that
numerous later authors will invoke and
probably a good place to go to that
would be the clerics monks and Mara jury
as a whole you know chapter of this
second it's worth noting that the
division of roles within the
relationship which flow from this more
general requirement of mutual affection
exhibited an eternal and temporal sacred
and secular matters too late modern here
is what stands out immediately as what
appears to be sort of traditional
affirmation of wifely obedience and
subjection a slightly more literal
rendering of the passage about obedience
would read the woman I want to comply
with the man in complete love and
Submission where this last trip submiss
you can also denote modesty gentleness
humility that such such submission as
anything that line in questioning
obedience is very clear given that the
wife's role also includes encouraging or
extorting her husband and until
attempting to calm him unjustly anger so
it's several letters by ansel two noble
wives thank and praise them for
precisely the sort of behavior his
exchanges with Queen Matilda are very
interesting as an example ansel not only
praises her attempts to bring out
reconciliation between himself and her
husband King Henry that is to lessen the
unjust and damaging anger of the King
against the archbishop he suggest to her
that she try to steer him away from bad
counselors he also advises are not only
to take care of her soul but to
encourage your husband to do likewise he
says reflect upon these things tell them
to our Lord King and puck in private and
in public and repeat them often so this
is far from a meek and acquiescence
submissiveness that answer
was putting forth as her wifely duty to
Matilda in fact one might go so far as
to say that wives are supposed to
participate in or at least eight and
encourage moral deliberation and
decision making in which their husbands
are involved handsome clearly does not
regard to treat women as men's inferior
zand their morale of rational capacities
he tells Matilda I am fully aware that
you can distinguish between good and
evil through the understanding of your
mind and he suggests that she interested
precisely so that she can help her
husband realize what would be
advantageous or beneficial for him there
by herself doing what is befitting to
you and what his advantageous for heaven
he does not hesitate to address her
complaints about his side of the
conflict through offering her moral
reasoning is expecting her in turn and
make this case to her husband letters
240 18 to 49 to Robert of Flanders and
his wife Clemente exhibit this general
approach as well and some rights to
Robert with whom he's enjoyed previous
conversations and hospitality and praise
and exhort adad a good Christian ruler
in order to encourage him further as a
good example to other princes and then
he writes to Clemente Oh telling her
that Roberts good action was not done
without his prudent clemency so I am
certain it was not done without your
club and prudence even though the an
some depicts this pair is demonstrating
themselves to be true children and
faithful advocates of the church the
spouse of God precisely because they
carry out it pertains to the Christian
religion in complete agreement so that
that cordia you nevertheless verjus it
is your duty to mention this and other
similar things frequently to your
husband in season and out of season so
again you know not sort of keep your
head down you know in some further asked
her to admonish motoring and the council
Robert in these matters so a wife's role
within the relationship of marriage
involves fur gotten some pages next up
involves her keeping her husband on
track morally this does not mean of
course that she's responsible for
husbands moral failures or vices unless
she's contributed to them a third set of
implications worth exploring a merchant
of duties on husband side and some
stress is his obligation to love his
wife as himself which implies a
volunteer and equalization of culturally
unequal statuses Anselm also insists the
husband is to care for the wife's body
as his own that is to provide for her
bodily needs and legitimate desires
which would by implication include
sexual desire a husband is also to
exhibit marital fidelity knowing no one
else but his spouse in fact Ansem
Chasen's the Irish King work at we're
could talk for countenancing what
appeared to be some pretty extreme
violations of monogamous commitment it
is first letter handsome rights we've
heard that in your kingdom marriages are
being dissolved and altered without any
grounds the second letter is more
explicit it said that husbands freely
and publicly exchange their wives or the
wives of others as if they're exchanging
one horse for another or anything
whatever for something from someone else
or they abandon them at their pleasure
without reason so in an Psalms view of
this represents practices and indeed
aspects of the culture as he says
entirely against the Christian religion
only mode contrary infidelity to one
spouse violates not only the commitment
of marriage but the purposes and duties
comprised within marriage in the day
similar to 10 of us and some uses
infidelity and susceptibility to
subduction as a metaphorical likeness or
the fallen and prideful even will so the
will is placed between God and the devil
in a way like a wife between our
legitimate husband or rightful husband
and some would-be adulterer her husband
charges her that she should be conjoined
to him alone but the adulterer persuades
her that she should copulate with him
and so if she is conjoined only to a
rifle husband she was a rightful wife
and she generates legitimate children
but if she joins herself to the
adulterer she is herself an adulteress
and brings forth adulterous children
this is a vital mastered metaphor within
an Psalms thought when a spouse
transgresses by breaking the bond of
marital fidelity pursuing her being
seduced by some other
harder this reflects the volition of the
on faith of that unfaithful spouse and
their will in turn has turn aside from
what it bought two will from being
conjoined with its legitimate spiritual
spouse that is the will of God so in a
marriage there's there's you know my
case my wife why should be conjoined
with my will should also be conjoined to
the world of God and I can commit by
committing adultery against her I also
from adulterer against God the
unfaithful persons will is conjoined
with the devil's and is thereby seduced
into willing something other than what
it ought to well given an Psalms
analyses of militia what is wrongfully
willed is at the very least two full one
wills whatever it is that motivates the
will in this case for example inordinate
or illegitimate enjoyment of sexual
pleasure one also at the same time wills
through and have an autonomous will
appropriate column times we were
discussing how to translate this well
could be self will as well a will that
one would like to be subject to no one
else's and nothing other than itself but
which ends up being captivated by even
subjected to its own desires and their
objects in the case of unchaste that an
adultery a variety of different motives
could provide the reason for the persons
wrong willing we ranging from revenge to
prestige from curiosity to desire to fit
in and of our own culture but in most
cases one can imagine that sexual desire
that is desire for sexual pleasure would
be a primary importance so this prompts
us to ask what Anselm's views on sexual
desire and the enjoyment of sexual
intercourse would be one natural place
to begin would be a second meditation
explicitly focused on virginity
unhappily lost there he employs the
language of uncleanness loss tension
fill he calls fornication a soya of his
mind his soul is an adulterer from
Christ her rightful spouse and is a
stubborn hora brazen fornicator leaving
her rightful spouse and coupling with
the devil one could perhaps derived from
this an interpretation of Anselm was
regarding human sexuality and its desire
and expression outside the marriage bond
is corrosive polluting more dangerous
and deleterious to the soul the mind the
will that is to the body
turning to the advice and admonition he
provides to the unfortunate gun Hilda
the last sentence of King Harold who had
taken religious orders then was
kidnapped by alum Rufus and married to
his brother Allen Eva after rufus's
untimely death we might draw similar
inferences he urges her consider how
great is the uncleanness of colonel
pleasure he warns of its consequences
for her fear of God's judgment shame in
this life a husband who gives and
promises only corruption and
contemptible things and who will sooner
or later spurn and desert her he tells
her to leave out her husband and
kidnapper to return to Christ her lawful
spouse suggesting we know of many holy
women who having lost their virginity
were more pleasing to God and were
closer to him through penitence and her
chastity than many others even though
holy in their virginity in a second
letter he becomes more explicit in
discussing the role of sexual desire and
pleasure he suggests there that mutual
lover desire developed between Allen
Rufus and can Hilda calling it your
beloved lover and arguing that she loves
his brother only for similarly carnal
reasons she runs as he says into his
embraces of which it is shameful to
speak either he attracts her away from
Christ or sheep if she herself pursues
him and he received a carnal log at the
time the letters are written gun Hilda
remains within the toils of Colonel
affection stained by and still pursuing
sexual pleasure committing fornication
even while seemingly married to her
captor these letters are particularly
helpful for filling in hansoms views on
marriage conjugal love and sexual desire
for some three reasons first he
explicitly mentions that the loss of
virginity is not an impediment to a life
of rectitude her holiness second he
notes that when discussing the wrongness
of sexual pleasure desired activity he
explicitly sets aside those within
lawful marriage 30 frames the badness of
carnal pleasure and desire in terms of
an adulterous and volitional turning
away from God and Gunnhild is
unfortunate case and she's become a nun
or marriage to either gallon with
interesting two brothers named the same
thing would not be legitimate and the
sexual pleasure and intercourse she
engages in with him could not be other
than
and I'm just so this leads to what for
many with you the part of the matter the
widespread caricature of Christian
conceptions of sexuality and marriage
construes human sexuality with the tent
that's a tenant desires acts and
pleasures as intrinsically are
necessarily sinful shameful disgusting
or law if that views marriage and sexual
intercourse within marriage that is the
act of conjugal love the serving two
ends what is a negative end better to
marry than to burn and I don't want to
say that that Paul is you know impious
this camp of people use that expression
and by restricting the object of one's
desires an ax to one prison one can
limit the deleterious effects of human
sexuality the other is a positive
procreation the reproduction of human
nature and new human beings one most
point out that it is the sexuality of
following human beings radically damaged
in both body and soul by original sin
that would be morally problematic in
need of being placed under the yoke of a
marriage in which sexuality is solely to
serve procreation does an some hammer
express such a perspective clearly he
considered sexual pleasure and activity
outside the bounds of what marriage
should be deeply wronged and morally
damaging but he also views these as
entirely appropriate within the
relationship of marriage what about
sexual desire itself in our fallen
condition it's not simply what and how
it ought to be as a consequence of
original sin we are subject to the
carnal appetites so the body became like
those of brute beasts subject to
corruption and the carnal appetites the
soul through the corruption of the body
and those same appetites through being
deprived of the goods as loss became
infected by those carnal appetites so
our corrupted bodies way out our souls
and the carnal appetites come into the
soul through the body so it seems the
soul itself becomes corrupted by the
body in terms of sexual desire perhaps
we experience it because of bodily
drives and conditions which that affect
our souls polluting them with experience
sexual desire and some explicitly
rejects any such an interpretation
strictly speaking according to him
there's nothing intrinsically right or
wrong good or bad about those carnal
appetites themselves he says is a sort
of long passage nor are those appetites
just or unjust considered
for they do not make a person feeling
them just or unjust but rather unjust
through the will of that person who
consents to them when he or she should
not if feeling those desires without
consenting to them were to make one
unjust then condemnation would follow
but it is not feeling them rather
consenting to them that is a sin if
indeed these appetites were unjust to
themselves they themselves would make a
person unjust when that person consented
to them but when the brute animals
consent to them they're not called
unjust irrational animals ought to feel
sexual desires in the way that they do
and indeed even when they act on those
desires consenting to them in so far as
they can consent there is no wrong in
the desire the act or the pleasure the
condition of human beings is different
of course because they're endowed with
reason which means they possess a
different much more complex free and
responsible faculty of will than do
other animals human beings can perceive
and understand and orient themselves in
relation to a fuller ranges of values
purposes relationships and persons their
wills are not only directed towards the
beneficial and away from the harmful
oriented by the inyx fungible
inclination for happiness but also stake
out positions in relation to justice and
injustice and compromising a higher type
and ordering of goodness so on the one
hand injustice morally wrong us or evil
does not reside in those appetites
themselves being felt by human being but
rather as Anselm says in the rational
will inordinately following them this
includes consenting to those desires but
could also include the intermediary
delighting in delicate anzio that an
some sets between the suggestion of
desires of Jesse oh the epictetus and
consent we are for the time being stuck
with and often be set with ignore that
sexual desire but we do at least possess
a capacity to order our own volitional
responses to that desire whether we
consent or not what we choose to do say
or even to think on the other hand the
things Colonel appetites dearest towards
including feeling sexual desire
engaging in sexual activity enjoying
sexual pleasure well not in themselves
unjust or morally wrong if voluntary
consent is not given our in certain
respects still bad at least for rational
beings and they kaasoo and some notes
with the will the happiness the deep and
ever abiding complex of our desires for
what appears to us beneficial and
conducive to happiness as it gets turned
away from more legitimate and fulfilling
objects it wills lower and unclean goods
that the rational animals delight in
this will is then unjust and blameworthy
Jesus on the side of the objects and the
felt desires for animalistic and join us
these are lower and unclean for human
beings on the side of the will
consenting to these that is where the
actual moral wrong and condemnation fall
but precisely because one is choosing
things appropriate too rash too
irrational animals of rational samples
and not choosing what better things
human beings are capable of including
the wealth of justice at the same time
and some points out that sexual
intercourse is a type of action that can
be engaged in not unjustly giving as an
examples the mating of the rational
animals or sexual intercourse between
married spouses as noted earlier this
listen asst extends not only to the act
of conjugal often to its pleasures as
well so know where it is works do we see
handsome concerned with condemning or
even counseling about the expression of
sexual desire within marriage even if
that desire stems in part from carnal
appetites his main concerns are rather
with adultery fornication and
incompatibilities between married life
and religious life which could be an
interesting topic to explore this does
not mean that once the vows are sad
morally speaking anything goes in
addition to the sorts of negative
limitations of positive aspirations
implicit and ansel advice to marry
people one would presume that they ought
to avoid or read out the vice of lust
which Anselm mentions and discusses in
the day similar to give us addicted sell
me his advice in those texts primarily
for the religious but presumably the
state of marriage would also be one in
which a Christian wife and husband are
similarly call to Z says drive out every
vice and arrange it so that evil
appetite does not resist good appetite
but rather good appetite always
subordinates
to itself this will of course require
cultivation and right use of the will
and reason and on the part of the
married couple the mutual assistance
love and friendship and care that Anselm
exhort something linen to close our
inquiries about the status of sexual
desire activity we might particularize
an analogy from the broader roles the
two wills man some small fear human
beings always possess it will is
inclination of an effect seal towards
happiness towards goods recognized or or
regarded as beneficial this is an
architectonic structure of the will
itself but it's not the only one there's
also the will to justice which is not
always present can be lost or abandoned
and which cannot be restored to a person
solely by their own powers or efforts to
the degree that it's capable in a person
the will to justice encompasses Orient's
and also restrains the will to happiness
which otherwise becomes more and more
disordered marriage itself when rightly
understood and lived out can be
understood as analogous to the will to
justice and a human being allowing
legitimates go for sexual desire
activity and pleasure but maintaining it
within proper balance precisely by
providing it a more encompassing
ordering an orientation one determined
and revealed by the other features of
goods a genuine marriage ought to
include for both spouses so if we want
to fit this then this is about all we
get from from explicit texts idanzel we
want to think about this enhance on
broader moral theory which is what I'm
trying to go with us we want to think
about marriage in terms of some of these
issues and this is not a exhaustive list
by any means we should think about how
one wills justly willing the right
things for the right reasons within
marriage and then how one would will
wrongly but and some things the
scriptures are a great guide for this
sort of thing you know when he's mini-z
ask you how do you isn't respond how do
you define justice but he gives a lot of
characterizations of what justice is
sometimes it's willing what God wills us
to
but it also says in some of the letters
you know if you want to know what God
wants you to will you should read the
scriptures or use your reason you know
and probably put the two of them
together so in marriage how does this
play out shaping the will to happiness
the the effect Sione's of the will in
terms of the world of Justice that could
happen within marriage given an self
consumptions of things particularly if
them it within the marriage you know the
wife is supposed to actually be paying
attention to her husband's moral status
and exhorting them I like to think that
if Anselm were around today he was that
both spouses want to be doing that
they're both spouses are you know
following all holiday of these sort of
things but that's an important idea what
ends our goods does conjugal love that a
sexual activity within marriage serve is
it a good in itself is it just
procreation satisfaction of desire or
should we see an song as sort of a
precursor as indeed you know leclerc
point about many of these monks writing
on fun marriage of the 12th century to
this notion that procreation is not the
only or fundamental good marriage that
intimacy is you know I did just for you
know one sort of interesting case to
think about think about Samson his
parents couldn't conceive let mean they
stopped having sex no as a matter of
fact Samson is born and it's you know
it's a some degree miraculous but
there's nothing that in the scriptures
that says yes and then God said for you
know I'm going to reward you by
implanting a child without you know you
actually engaging in conjugal up so I
think Anselm is in certain ways a good
representative if you dig things out of
his works because of this this you know
discussion of the type of love that a
couple should have with each other for
saying that the sexual act
conjugal laws should be oriented towards
intimacy so it's self donation as we say
now like [ __ ] hildenbrand John Paul the
second what happens when once wrong has
been done how do you restore it damaged
marriage that would be something that
could be look differently on some in
perspective and then finally I close by
you know thinking about what do spouse
is actually fold to each other Ansel's
moral theory you know this term Deborah
is absolutely central justice is doing
what you want to do there's more to it
than that but that that thought what is
it that spouses actually do Oh to each
other and if they fail to give it to
each other they're they're falling down
on the job and committing injustice
Ansem says they should be loving each
other they should be developing
friendship and I think that there's a
lot of resources in hansoms discussion
of friendship with between monks and
nuns and is discussions of Concordia and
what it means in terms of the will that
could be directly applicable to the
marriage so I'm not going to say in a
marriage can be should we turn into
something like a little mini monastic
community because obviously there's been
very different locations yeah you know
I'm Way out of my depth at actually you
know speculation about that sort of
thing but I think that that Anselm's
advice and he gives copious copious
advised among some nuns about how they
ought to be living out the Christian
life a lot of that would be very
applicable to how married couples want
to look at each other so that's that's
what I've got
I'm very happy the eggs or suggestions
there they should go from from people
because they get bit off a bit more than
I easily digest yeah I got a question
for you since my my own experience is
much more with the variable flowering of
the 12th century down on these questions
given that in some doesn't have a lot
specifically on this do you have any
sense of where Anselm fits in
perspective of his contemporaries I'm
familiar with the idea of marriage being
related to friendship as being a leader
concept than end zone yeah so was he
distinctive in this regard and you have
discovered that well it's not that much
later that we have the flowering right
you know and where's the flowering what
sources the flowering drawing up you
might say they're they're countering to
classical sources added versus Cicero
all right Ovid you know they run the art
of love and they commented on it
sometimes a ella garage some of the
sometimes it is ready sir [ __ ] book
cicero's de you know I'm friendship is
damaged etf was wrecked and that's where
this red amare comes from that attains
such an important status is loving in
return what is that who is that comprise
and cicero you know of course sod is
primarily between men not between
Amanda's wife he had some terrible
relations of his wife but the monks you
know in the 12th century we're applying
this the day on Acadia exclusive it's a
marriage I think handsome he's reading
them you know he's got a library yeah I
think it's one of those things that we
don't have a lot of discussions about he
just didn't talk about it much it was
morally council otherwise the one other
thing I want to point out to us there's
nothing to suggest that he actually gave
advice to working-class people about
their
all stuff that we have is to know this
noble a great yeah well somebody who
could read it to them why also Gabbar
doesn't suggest that in any way so we
don't know you know if he actually was
you know apparently get a charism for
for giving advice to people that really
fit their for station well but we don't
know when we gave it to because if the
Opera doesn't that's a long rambling
sure yeah more than metaphysical
question look at what so you were
talking about the bodily appetites kind
of affecting the soul I guess how does
that happen how does that happen but
what sort of he doesn't tell us a story
he doesn't have an account to that but
he's more interested in the stuff on the
soul and you know it has to do with with
will weather the will consents to those
appetites now this is where if we were
sort of extrapolate from Ansel and say
one of you know what if Ansel would like
to sit down and get more more detailed
discussion on this the will to happiness
for an song is you know he distinguishes
between will as like the instance of
will the actual willing that uses the
instrument itself and then these
factions in clay
and one of these is the will to end
because that's always there in us and it
leads us towards what appeared to us
beneficial or away from the harmful and
that's that's that's where we can end up
sort of being damaged that's he doesn't
come out and say vices reside in the
will to happiness but that's the only
place they could you know within the
structure you can correct me if I'm
wrong on this but that's the only place
I see that that within his his sort of
anthropology vices could could reside
lasting habitual structures and so the
carnal appetites and think about if I if
I feel lost and that Colonel appetite is
coming to me he's got this sort of three
per thing which is not original T on
there's there's the suggestion by the
appetite that there's a sort of
delighting in it considering it talked
about this more on the dict on Sony and
then there's the actual consent of the
will I sort of take it on it's a i'ma go
do that you know thing I'm not supposed
to do over there we damage ourselves in
the process by this and we can look at
the way in which things work with low
like a one-time sort of deal the way in
which we live as human beings is over
time and so if I've given in to my
carnal appetites I'm sort of setting
myself up to a harder time even after
justice is restorative well a lot you
know maybe I keep working after
something like that but he doesn't give
us a lot of discussion mechanics that
physical mechanism
yeah so you talked about friendship you
know the dancing friendship has
important and when you mention that the
passage were commanded husband's loving
the wives is that how do you think of of
Caritas or other forms of love it were
they part of friendship or was well I am
small Richard that's something opposed
tonight no I Absalom does not think that
that I makita caritas were two distinct
kinds of love so he's not a CS lewis for
for lumps kind of guy and actually a lot
of you know lot of authors Alexio makita
Caritas or these all tend to go outside
even even in Thomas Aquinas we see that
there's a lot of overlap between these
you know Carrie tests the perfectional
blog that could happen in terms of
friendship so gentle does talk quite a
bit about about Caritas as well and the
real friendship is going to have its
going to be inhabited by card ethos and
a real friendship this is where it gets
really interesting a real friendship
which could be a family relation it
could be you know between us and
colleagues it could be my wife and I
it's it's going to involve a concordance
of will where neither one of us tries to
force our own will on the other tries to
work for the benefit of the other and
we're we're certain getting in through
through charity so why's it doesn't
involve you know sitting and it's
necessarily going to extend itself more
broadly than just our individual
relationship because too at the very
least it's going to you know we're
hopefully going to be in harmony with
the rest of the church you know those in
heaven insofar as nuts because we're
screwed up to Larry love is imperfect
but it also should extend within
temporal society as well if my wife and
I are really having a good marriage that
should spill over into how things are
between myself some colleagues little or
they got a very far ranging answer I
just wanted to mention an answer to the
sort of influence question in a bit yes
don't talk about yeah friendship between
oh yeah so that be yeah I'm a good of
marriage the horses obviously it's read
the confessions and here's Monica you
know you're going to temper the you know
that the angry husband and I feeling in
some had a sort of similar families set
up oh yeah like a good relationship with
his dad yeah I'm worried about it hit up
his Dan he couldn't yeah you couldn't
get along that's a really interesting
point and I didn't put it in here but
there are these letters to his sister
and her husband and they don't tell us
an awful lot about you know what
marriage a lot to look like some of it
is oh my outside work oh yeah someone is
sort of you know should he should he go
off and go on pilgrimage that that's
fine a sort of thing but then some of it
is about you know consoling them for how
many of their children died and that
those children are going to be you know
there is sort of part of the community
now with them yeah and some himself did
not have a happy family mother dies
fairly young as daddy's left with his
daddy
can't get along with tries to get away
you know so I yeah I think that there
could be maybe he doesn't write about
marriage that much because he didn't see
that enough in his his own life I don't
really know why he needed I can tell you
this to make sure nothing against didn't
of it yeah yeah that there could be that
too or or you know it's not just a
Gustin but also Gregory and Ambrose and
people all written about you know to
some degree the duties that people have
to each other the last thing I'll say is
Ansel doesn't spend much time talking
about lust when it comes to the vices I
thought of big one for you but that's
typically monastic because you know if
you look at lust and gluttony you want
to get those under control those aren't
the ones that are really problematic
it's pride and the vainglory those sorts
of things those will tear you tear you
apart these are just bottling you know
so he doesn't spend that much thank you
very much